[Applause]
and the cast of real-time all right here
are the questions Noah but this could be
for everybody what would it take for
Republicans to break with Trump publicly
I heard was it Ben Sasse or Jeff Flake
one of them said if if they took the
vote privately 30 to 35 Republicans
would vote to impeach but that's not
publicly what would it take
yeah that's kind of hard to believe but
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be off that
by that much I mean ever have Italy
privately yeah so what would it take it
would take for them to believe their
political prospects are imperiled and
that might sound like you know it's a
moral failure and you could view it that
way but it's the fact and so if you
start to see polls of impeachment that
begin to swallow up a lot of
Independence and 20 percent 30 percent
of Republicans then yeah you're gonna
see where some Republicans jump ship
okay Barney do you think Democrats will
be able to stay united and on message
throughout the impeachment process or
will the you know or the divisions
between progressives and moderates
re-emerge it is a it is a bit of a
minefield for that that's true thanks to
Nancy Pelosi we will be united and she
took on the people who way the future in
feature and she has impeccable
credentials now against anyone who says
all you were just looking for an
impeachment yeah he's been very firm on
that and now there is one possibility I
hope and I know this is her position
stay on the interference in the election
by trying to smear the candidate he most
fears by holding up weapons that the
Ukrainians needed to defend themselves
against the trend Putin killing back
into some of the side issues about
paying for stormy Daniels I hope and I
hope they are stay out of that I believe
they will and I think that YES on this
question now of focusing on the I think
the defense of the national interest in
democracy by going after what Trump did
she'll have almost public unanimity okay
what do you think Winnett you are
business you are a business insider of
course of the US Census Bureau reporting
income inequality is now at a 50-year
high I mean I think that
it sounds like it's time to deliver a
message a lot like the one that Trump
delivered four years ago and I don't
think he's going to be able to do that I
was just in a room a message being
everything is [ __ ] up and I alone can
fix it after four years of Trump I see
his surrogates out there I was just in a
room of Wall Streeters and Mike Pence
and he was doing the victory lap we won
capitalism is back we're here to win
blah blah blah everyone's winning and
that didn't even go well down well in a
room of suits I don't understand how
Trump is gonna be able to circle that
Square and say not only am i the victim
and I'm screwed and everything's [ __ ]
up and you know wrong but also I just
won the last four years and you should
reelect me the winning message is yeah
inequality is terrible we have a corrupt
society crony capitalism that's still a
winning message I think for a lot of
Americans and it's gonna be really hard
to see the Trump administration say we
did it we're winners but also say you're
[ __ ] your victims let me win it for
you can I just add a gratuitous
conservative talking point to this yeah
that study also showed that the median
American income is the highest it's ever
been in the mid-60s so while income
equality is broad more Americans are
doing better yeah can I say in response
to that the median doesn't help the
people who are losing and the fact is
that median is one thing and there are
other people who doing well but not only
a lot of people are not doing well but
Trump has failed to help them chumps
that's the other issue manufacturing
isn't a slump
we're seeing that slump move into the
services sector the recession isn't just
a fear it's something that's a distinct
possibility especially given the fact
that we're gonna continue this
ridiculousness with China and now we're
we've we've started [ __ ] with the EU
they're also beginning it's the world is
starting to be a mess no matter how much
central banks loosen policy we're still
seeing as an economic growth is
decreasing decreasing he himself is
looking for scapegoats for an economy
that's getting worse
and what happens politically by the way
is it the trend is what count even
the absolute but clearly inequality it's
worse than when he started and he has
done zero to make it better it'll make
it worse
how does he say I'm winning but you're
looking said it was gratuitous he wasn't
good for arguments I you know I
understand all this Trump did promise
something is delivered on nothing and
the main remind you in 68 Nixon ran on
the idea at the pledge I'm going to end
the war in Vietnam he didn't and then
four years later in 1972 he ran on the
platform I'm going to end the war in
Vietnam that's a Salesman ok he also
drew my gun George McGovern was
unfortunately the candidate ok all right
Geena which Democratic candidate has put
forth the best policy to address climate
change well that's it that's a good one
whose River I will I will take them all
because I was so excited that they
actually had a climate debate somebody's
about climate deal you know the winner
in the climate debate seemed to be
Governor Inslee one day right because
everybody stole from his plans and gave
them credit for it so but I think the
most important thing right now is to
recognize how much people now are
feeling and seeing the impacts of
climate change how much that that people
running for office recognize that
they're not going to pander to it
they're developing real plans we have to
do something and gets in your backyard
you know well California but I mean
things used to be more alive there would
birds and butterflies and every day I
see bees walking
[Laughter]
it makes me almost cry like the old
Indian the commercial I see Abby walking
like bees are not supposed to be walking
and this B is obviously domestic
politically this is the first
presidential campaign ever in which
climate change has been a significant
room and it's entirely because Donald
Trump took that position literally
nobody they kind of took it for granted
and maybe fights about more or less but
Trump has elevated it and I think to his
disadvantage okay Salman Indian Prime
Minister Modi recently appeared at it I
was in Houston Sunday my luck I'm in
Houston
once every two years on there the day
fatso arrived Modi do you think and
there was twenty five thousand screaming
Indians yeah there for Trump yeah they
were holding hands he and Modi you saw
that I saw okay do you think Trump's
pushed to appeal to Indian Americans
will be effective but he did say seems
if he seemed popular there at Music's
unfortunately I'm sorry to say about my
people that a whole chunk of the voted
for Trump last time around they did they
did and and the Modi deal and I mean
Modi's pitch and Trump's are not so far
apart right now in that they well it's a
particular kind of nationalism which
they both invent a fairy tale of the
past in order to justify actions in the
present so in Trump we have the Red Hat
you know this Golden Age of America that
we're supposed to get back to and Modi
is doing the same thing he's inventing a
much more distant golden age a golden
age of Hinduism that predated the
arrival of the Muslim invaders uses that
to justify attacking minorities you know
and brexit is the same thing there's a
very similar I very tale of England you
think it's a fairy tale
yeah because the Golden Age is always a
fairy tale the the idea that there was
such a thing as a golden age of
universal happiness and prosperity it's
a factor so what about Camelot wasn't
there a place I know you break into song
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]
you